Let's calculate the average and standard deviation in this spreadsheet. After
you Copy and Paste the engagement data into your own spreadsheet. Then in any
blank cell, we'll type equals average, and in this case, B2 column B236. And if
we go to the bottom, we see that there are 236 rows, but the first row has a
header. So there are 235 values. Now we have the mean in cell E1. Now in cell
D2, we can type equals parentheses B2 minus $E$1, and parentheses.
[INAUDIBLE]
2, for squared. So that's the first squared deviation from the mean. We'll Copy
that cell. I'll go to cell C2, hit Cmd, Down Arrow. Go to cell D236, Cmd
,Shift, Up arrow key. Highlighting column D, Cmd V. Now we have all our squared
deviations. The average squared deviation is the variance, equals average D2
column D2, 36. There's our variance, and now the standard devation is the
square root of cell E2. There you have it. Let's round to the 100th place. We
get the mean is 7.47 and the standard deviation is 2.41, if we round two
decimal places.